junge leute herzlich willkommen zu einer
trommel in mein will wo ich auch die ein
oder andere sache erklären werde
erzählen werde erzählen wählen ihr wisst
bescheid und zwar als erstes gibt es mal
eine projektinfo und zwar habe ich ein
projekt ausgedacht was ich mit als erste
mal mit dem kokon crafter betreuung
werde den kette vielleicht und in diesem
projekt wird es darum gehen dass ich
diese dass wir uns gegenseitig tweets
von moneyball vorlesen deswegen als das
projekt auch moneyball runde und
verloren hat wer als erstes drei mal
gelacht hat und wir haben gerade im
schon mal ausprobiert auf dem teamspeak
server und es war so geil also das war
richtig richtig lustig also können wir
glauben dass wird ultra do wenn das
kommt und ja ich bin gerade viel zu dumm
um den jazz zu finden
ich habe keine ahnung was mit mir ab
geht ja wie gesagt ist auch meine erste
aufnahme alleine deswegen weiß ich bin
architekt if hingehört mein gott
naja ok da machen wir jetzt machen ist
eine 400 raus ihr könnt aber ich kann
auch drüber lachen
es passiert ja doch noch ein päckchen
wurden cert wer das gedacht wer hätte es
fucking gedacht ich wäre halt einfach
mal machen wie gesagt wenn man einfach
keine keine päckchen findet aber keine
kisten ja päckchen weil ich das
kraftwerk von 6 3 ab deswegen sind
päckchen auch normalerweise kissen ja
wenn man keine findet dann nicht so geil
und wir werden ein bisschen rumlaufen
unser live talk master so geht und wer
uns abmeldet also an acted justins
anleger er weder aufs maul der balance
mal okay vettel doch noch mal
projektleiter und ein pfeil alters ist
luxus luxus alter luxus okay ja was die
taktik ist heilig beim tester seien aber
habe ich kann nicht so bock drauf
deswegen demokratie wird auch dienste
detektive nennen aber ich mache einfach
mein ding ich lass mir nix sagen von den
leuten und ja wie gesagt das projekt das
wird man lieben heißt akademie mich
boxen habe ich nicht so bock drauf weil
er mich boxen ja wieder vor fischer
alter verpiss dich
wofür gibt es eigentlich gewesen
und ja dieses projekt mit manni heißen
und es wird ultra lustig sein also das
könnt ihr mir glauben es wird ultra
ultra ultra geil richtig richtig lustig
wird und deswegen könnt euch darauf
freuen wird bis wird demnächst kommen
wenn ihr wahrscheinlich morgen die erste
folge auf da kommt vielleicht okay
natürlich dann auf mich kommt
wahrscheinlich übermorgen dann das erste
video hoch und ja ich würde jetzt aber
mein renn dunkel
wer will in rechnung gestellt werden
verringern auf uns entwickelt ok jetzt
für alle leute die denken ja grübel
zerfällt
da kann ja gar nix wie gesagt das war
jetzt einfach so eine runde so schlecht
wie sie sein kann
na gut ich hab noch keine instanz
gekippt aber das wird diesmal kommen
wollen sie daraus dass er über das
wetter
wo eltern küper fall was kommt dann
bitte her kann man gar nicht klar
okay das ist auch mal safe einen trade
drin deswegen wir uns immer vor knöpfen
an den boxen
also wie gesagt das projekt kommt das
wird richtig gar ich freue mich darauf
mit extrem lustig und es gibt es noch zu
sagen sonst gibt es noch zu sagen dass
ich ja ich hab nicht nur dieses projekt
auf lager hat noch einige andere
projekte auf lager und ihr oder picken
aber ich bin nicht wichtig war bin ich
fit bin ich fit bin ich fit bin ich fit
bin ich fit bin ich weg war wirklich
wirklich wirklich als pfeile was geht ab
bei dem was geht ab fasst gerd längst
kann sich fange keiner bis figaro
schalter die heutige pisten ecke
das war der altar visa fällt ja wie auch
immer das war eine feier runde
ich werde auch so nennen und ja
eigentlich wollte ich euch in dem video
zu informieren dass das projekt mit
krupp kraft am morgen kommt seid mir
nicht böse wenn ich hier gefällt wie
gesagt es war absicht ja da macht's gut
haut rein und wir sehen uns bald wieder
hier auf sks